- I bet children do this.
Look at my lychee nipples!
Hillary, please.
(upbeat music)
- You never had lychee?
- No, I don't know what lychee is.
- I know what lychee the fruit is.
It comes in brown skin, kind of sweet,
and on the very very inside
is a very smooth pit.
- They put those little
(bleep) in my drink sometimes
and it startles me.
(upbeat music)
- How do I eat it, like a jello shot?
- Mine's not opening.
- Well the child proof is on.
Think I need a grown-up to
open this thing. (laughs)
- It smells like perfume.
- This is for classy ladies to wear out,
not for children to eat.
- Look if you see the little chunks,
you can see through them which is bizarre.
- Oh, there's juice coming out!
- Do I just suck it?
(slurping)
- Oh, it's so much better
tasting than it smells!
- That's too much, too much!
- That's really, really good.
You don't like it, I can tell.
- I might have another one.
(slurping)
- Mmm.
- It tastes like sugar and perfume,
and somehow that's not terrible tasting.
- And it had little
bits of the fruit in it.
- It tastes like a fruit cup
that I would get in my
lunch pail as a kid.
- I feel like if hipsters knew
about this they'd love it.
- I would eat this as a kid
'cause I ate worse things than this,
I grew up in Brooklyn, bro.
- Coconut's like super underrated,
and I think it makes everything better.
- Now I have milky nipples! (laughs)
I'm gonna do this every time.
- Whole box smells like
a Bath and Body Works.
- Ugh!
(slurping)
- It's very coconut-y, it's too coconut-y.
- Coconut-y chemicals.
- Yeah little bits of chewy coconut.
That was delicious.
- Alright, let's get this
outta the way, patow!
- I'd say mango is an overrated flavor.
One time, made something with
a mango, and I didn't like it.
(laughing)
- Smells like artificial flavor.
(slurps)
- It's got tiny hard chunks
in it that I've been avoiding.
- Halfway between a mango lassie
and a mango juice from a can.
- They're horrible, don't
recommend to any kid.
- This just seems like
a delicious fruit snack
that American children are missing out on.
- This is the best candy I've
ever tried in a taste test.
- Great children's candy,
also great adult candy.